so interesting the waves information
they're coming out based around this
Jordan that's insane
isn't it cool and it's gonna be cool to
see because the Jordan dock his legacy
was that the highest has been in 20
since 1997 1998 like after they dropped
it yeah by the end of the last dance
where Jordan is back dude he's 100
percent maybe more godlike than ever
right but then you're starting to hear a
story by story and I don't think I'm
curious to know how much it'll chip away
cuz each story keeps a little bit away
from what he presented himself as do you
think that this ends up hurting his
legacy I don't know and that's my
question is in the long run will it chip
away from it so much that you're like he
should have done this documentary
differently that's the thing it's like
when he initially put it out I'm like
cemented that's it statue he's the goat
nobody could touch him but he's put when
you say you're the goat you're basically
inviting the discussion from everyone
else how you aren't and we will hear the
loudest voices will be your detractors
yeah so when what's it mother [ __ ]
name Tim Duncan goes honestly I was
never really impressed I sent you this I
meant to send you I think I said to Al
bison but it was like Tim Duncan comes
out and goes
honestly I blues never really impressed
by Michael Jordan but I'm not really
impressed by anybody like you never even
hear that discussion if last dance isn't
out because nobody's going to Tim Duncan
and saying so what was your thoughts
about Michael yeah so he's inviting the
criticism in an age where criticism is
the loudest microphone no matter what
yeah so when this story about Scottie
Pippen coming out and saying that he
thought Kobe was better than might be
better than mine that happened before
the documentary came in is also if you
watch the quote he's like I thought Kobe
was better than him because he just
worked so hard and he didn't have
training and he's like oh you're saying
MJ was better but Kobe worked harder and
you liked him and he didn't have a great
coach which he did what she did yeah but
it is interesting like to see people
slowly start to chip away man yeah like
slowly start to chip away and I wonder
if Jordan was better off if his legacy
was actually more intact intact before
social media because social media
couldn't it
do anything to disintegrate that
reputation because it wasn't even in
question it was just like yeah he's to
go but let's not really discuss it maybe
LeBrons to go now
is it LeBron is he the best whatever but
you weren't really talking about what
Jordan did or didn't do and now people
coming out and saying Narborough Jordan
actually wasn't that tough like I
stepped to him and he didn't do [ __ ] see
I think if he just presented himself as
I was obsessed with winning and if he
was even remorseful like I was pretty
hard on some teammates like you know
like I've [ __ ] up if he was just more
like and not I was hard on teammates but
I well I did them a favor they won
because of me which is true but it was
always his shade of the truth you're
opening up the door and if that
sometimes he straight-up lying and if
you do a better job of being objective
over and your you have and this is hey
every girl needs somebody's willing to
push back and this is again the value of
a fill the director ain't fill the
director is gonna say okay you want to
say like a so say like this if you had a
Phil Jackson type director to be like
hey man is that true you know you sure
you you were okay with Isaiah being on
the team and there was no conversation
because if not it's a [ __ ] problem
you're gonna look like an [ __ ]
hundred percent I'm gonna push back a
little bit he didn't have that one lie
eliminates all your truths it really
does trust is super fragile and that's
the thing it's like every statement that
he said in that documentary or that was
even portrayed in the document because
now we know he put out the Edit for the
documentary and he co-signed everything
that was out there right this wasn't a
third party right with the Lance
documentary I don't think is Lance I
think if someone else making it he just
agreed to it but this is Jordans dock so
Jordan is controlling narrative if one
lie comes out now we questioned every
other truth yet we start to go oh [ __ ]
weren't people really that afraid of
talking [ __ ] to him and him holding a
grudge were they just making that up for
the documentary because if they could
make up the fool poison thing they could
make up that Sam Smith also said he lied
about something it I send that story or
he said they lied about the food
poisoning and he said he lied about my
seventh year yeah and I knew they
weren't coming back yeah I knew that was
we early in the documentary and then
there's a scene I remember we all
remember he's in the hotel room alone
and he's like I'm not gonna miss
yeah this all like I'm inside in my
hotel room and I can't do anything this
is this is my only time alone that
moment I remember being like oh he was
done here he knew he was done and then
he comes out and says I it's maddening I
didn't get to do a seventh year and it's
like well you could have play for
somebody else you only want to play for
Phil you didn't want to go to another
team you could have gone to the Knicks
giving the Knicks a championship been
God God God bro
I loved Michael Jordan but I wonder if
there's a lesson to be learned here
which is if you're already considered
the goat screaming at the top of your
lungs are putting out a documentary that
goes on the goat in a biased way in a
biased way only puts you in the
situation where you could be criticized
yep and can chip away from your goat
status yep I don't think he was
considered to goat like there were way
more discussions of who's better LeBron
and Jordan now because of this
documentary we've all seen that okay no
Jordan was definitely better than the
prom so I think he needed this to cement
himself in our generation it had been
done more objectively or if he's only
focused with his only focus was I wanted
to win more than everything winning was
the only thing that mattered and that
was it and it wasn't all the other [ __ ]
then we might have been like yo this
dude was obsessed with winning in a way
that Ron isn't I think our cars made a
great point because if he was more of an
[ __ ] in this documentary yeah we
would believe everything that he said
yeah I wanted Isaiah the dream team [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] him [ __ ] him I ain't like oh
[ __ ] him and you know what the goat gets
to do that you know say like yeah if you
showcase every single story if you say
every single thing they have matter of
fact you even have some humility if
you're always like you know what I
stepped to Robert Parish that's a big
[ __ ] well although a Steve Kerr
something like that you ain't always get
my way I mean I know yeah I tried to
push sometimes I push buttons too far I
regret some of the things that is
sometimes people call me on my [ __ ] son
I really think if it was like you said
if it was just focus on how much that
what he was willing to do to win no
matter what it all costs we would look
at LeBron and go Mack he's not willing
to win it all cost like Jordan
solidified but when you build yourself
up into this kind of folk hero which he
did yeah he turned himself into a one of
these wild
heroes from the movies that he loves to
watch and we all bought it but it was
stupid that we bought it in retrospect
cuz it's like this can't all of you so
and we live in the information age right
now we can go to every single person
that was in that documentary no is this
what happened and they have the ability
true or false
to chip away in it that's dangerous bro
I'm just saying the only people you're
hearing negative things from are the B
level besides this is audio of let's
play this clip this is audio I'm gonna
read the tweet audio of Michael Jordan
admitting he told Rod Thorn that he
wouldn't play on the dream team if
Isaiah was on it let's hear and this is
from this is from a podcast Jordan did
or an interview Jordan did a long time
ago
right years ago maybe decades ago so
this is a 23 second sound bite if we
can't get the audio right we'll just
read the quote that's probably the
article let's do it we got it
hello well into later what's going on I
don't know probably something's this
Court is breaking down his only good
scroll up I think the article that has a
quote Rod Thorn called me I said rod
I said rod I won't play if Isaiah Thomas
is on the team he assured me he said you
know what Chuck being Chuck Daly which
we also speculate it doesn't want Isaiah
so Isaiah is not going to be a part of
the team you probably Chuck part of
Chuck didn't want him on that [ __ ] see
ya I knew something happened there if
you soured with the coach that took you
to two championships you're an [ __ ]
you're a piece of [ __ ] real time and if
Jordan said I didn't want to on the team
yeah [ __ ] Larry didn't like him Chuck
Daly his own coasting won a month team
why is anybody on the team and he was
1992 Isaiah 9 1988 Isaiah he's not the
same player I'm up to I need him on the
team also he's probably not the only
person said he didn't want him on the
team yeah a lot of people probably said
they didn't one of them a team I I think
it'd be better if he was honest yep
brutal honesty let us know how [ __ ] up
you are Mary doesn't like you treat your
teammates there we go
yeah maybe he wasn't brutally honest all
this [ __ ] I think just came out of his
insecurity like he greenlit the
documentary after the
LeBron won the finals yeah a parent you
hear that yeah he green let the after
LeBron came back from 3-1 he grew the
doctor like he just fell all this
insecurity and then had to like lie
about like what do you do when you're
insecure you start like embellish and
[ __ ] inflating your you said there's a
lesson here maybe to be learned as much
as we love Jordan I think Jordan teaches
us a lot of lessons on what to do and
what not to do he's teaching lessons all
the time
whether he realizes it or not what to do
in a lot of ways how hard to work all
that [ __ ] the singular focus on winning
that's all you can do all that what not
to do don't be Jordan now this unhappy
miserable [ __ ] in a mansion just
yellow-eyed [ __ ] drunk all the time
smoking cigars yeah bro when you are on
a like you didn't even fact check your
own [ __ ] yeah you didn't remember saying
publicly I don't want this guy on the
team about a controversy has existed for
decades yeah I'm not a lot Jordan
strikes me as a type of dude they
believes his own lies yeah well that
makes perfect sense you know how you
like saw in the documentary he made up
that labrat birds the engines or
whatever love that for Smith whatever
the [ __ ] his name was like he said
something that I took in person he said
good game and I took a person what an
[ __ ]
yeah so I was like he strikes me as a
type of guy who goes no I don't think I
ever told Rod Thorn and then just starts
believing that he didn't tell Rod Thorn
yeah and he just believes whatever
reality he's in because it benefits him
to believe that that's true and that is
like a telltale sign of a psychopath or
at least sociopath one of those two you
just start believing these things are
real yeah and yeah it's kind of a shame
man oh god imagine this actually killed
his legacy that'd be really sad I don't
think he I mean I think there's always
gonna be it's just gonna go back and
forth so there's gonna be a tipping
point where it's too far we're hating on
Jordan we forget he's the best and I
think I'll even out if Scotty comes out
and he was like and he starts chipping
away and he has every reason yeah but
the Scotty comes out he starts chipping
away well that's not a good look for me
and for MJ just don't look like he's
hating fair enough
because if all the goats in the dock
prays Jordan God like that's the word I
need if your contemporaries who are the
best at that time are saying no you're
the best
I don't care what the other role players
are saying about me who is who we
government like magic Larry like they're
saying yeah but they're also guys he
didn't play against LeBron like there's
never gonna be guys who played against
but I'm just saying like at that time
he's the greatest so it's like we can't
Jordan will never play against LeBron in
their prime so we'll never know like
really had them head to head but I'm
just saying from what we saw in the doc
from what we saw in real life and then
what we see from LeBron right now it's
like Jordans the best I don't deny
shortens the best that's how I was like
people can take all these knocks at him
it's not going to he thrown him here's
one same I don't deny that he's the best
and I think he is the best prior to the
documentary I thought he's the best the
documentary has solidified it in a lot
of ways for me that being said I think
he's opened up more doors for criticism
yeah and the documentary instead of
closed them and the idea behind the
documentary I presume was I'm a close
all the doors there's the United this
conversation LeBron
you're not even in this conversation
Kobe nobody's in this conversation it's
just me I'm the goat and now of a sudden
you can see a door open over here where
it's like yeah me it was good but he was
kind of a bully or that a done door open
here like skywars grant said I'll fight
you right now so if the stories coming
out he wouldn't let Horace Grant eat and
now Horace is like I'll fight you right
the [ __ ] now what you gonna do if you're
Jordan you have to fight this guy or you
look kind of like you might have been
lying or you have something coming out
where it's like yo Dennis Rodman was one
of the greatest basketball players to
ever play basketball he just didn't
really score the ball that much but the
fact that he played the game the way he
did it allowed Michael to be successful
and then it comes out that whoa Scottie
Pippen was actually the second best
player in the NBA during Jordans career
and he happened to be on Jordan's team
like if all these things start coming
out like whoa that was actually the
first Super team and not only did they
have a big three they had a four Toni
Kukoc was one of the best players and
it's like is that the most talented team
ever more talented than the Warriors all
I'm saying is doors are opening I don't
know where all these doors will open and
you're like whoa that was not the goal
of this documentary yeah
[Applause]